avant de l'entendre nous allons parler
d'un sujet qui nous concerne tous vous
avez vu des reportages à la télé
évidemment dessus ces derniers jours ça
concerne le stress de la rentrée Marie
Estelle Dupont nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau marie-est Dupont qui est
psychologue Maxime Guinée est toujours
là Sophie cost évidemment
tu pourrais être ma mère il vient de me
dire
on a été très interpellé on a été
vraiment interpellé par un sondage
iPhone donc c'est très sérieux 95% des
Français sont stressés
ça veut dire qu'on est tous stressés en
général et par la rentrée un peu plus
évidemment au cours partout les enfants
le travail la fin des vacances aussi ont
été pas mal en vacances ont été
détendues et puis voilà il faut s'y
remettre et c'est pas évident Marie
Estelle Dupont est-ce que vous le
constatez vous déjà à travers vos
consultations est-ce que vous vous
constatez qu'au mois de septembre il y a
un regain de stress chez chez vos
patients je le constate dans cette
rentrée parce que et c'est d'ailleurs le
sujet de mon livre en fait le la crise
sanitaire a quand même laissé des traces
durable c'est à dire que les mesures
sont levées mais il y a un état de
stress chronique latent dans l'ensemble
de la population avec beaucoup de gens
qui ont aussi des comporté des troubles
psychologiques qui ne sont pas encore
régulés bon après elle a rentré il
normalement il y a aussi un enthousiasme
parce que on a on a repris de l'énergie
alors si vous êtes stressé à la rentrée
c'est soit que le rythme de l'année ne
vous convient pas et il va falloir
prendre cette année pour le modifier
soit qu'en fait vous faites des vacances
qui ne vous conviennent pas mais vous
l'avez pas encore admis vous n'avez pas
encore admis que 15 jours chez vos
beaux-parents ça ne vaut mieux
c'est pas du tout des vacances une
semaine de randonnée à la montagne en
parlant à personne peut-être dans votre
cas que deux semaines dans votre
belle-famille ça peut être une source de
stress déjà pendant les vacances on
parle du stress mais en fait il y a le
stress ou le blues c'est à dire qu'en
général pour les gens qui ont des
enfants sur une tonalité de stress et
pour les gens qui ont pas d'enfant on
est plus sur une tonalité de nostalgie
de quitter les vacances avec un risque
de rentrer dans la routine du couple et
ça c'est plutôt un écueil pour les gens
qui ont pas d'enfant les gens qui ont
des enfants bah oui il y a une charge
mentale il faut synchroniser plein
d'agenda ouvrir 472 fenêtres dire à son
mari et monotache voilà mais en fait il
y a plein de petits tips on fait toutes
on fait tous les ans la rentrée donc on
ne peut que réussir et il y a plein
d'astuces assez simple et des autres
pendant les vacances les enfants des
autres si on a une famille recomposée
par exemple
je vous le dis pour l'année prochaine du
coup anticiper c'est à dire que faites
en juin ou juillet tout ce que vous
n'aurez pas à faire en septembre vider
les placard trier les vêtements etc et
puis le fait de beaucoup s'organiser
d'avoir plein de plans à plan B parce
qu'il y a des c'est souvent s'organiser
c'est juste avoir une baby-sitter de
secours pour la baby-sitter de secours
qui va vous planter
en fait et du coup vous savez qu'il y a
toujours une branche avec elle vous
rattrape bon est-ce que vous avez
quelques conseils à nous donner très
pratique Marie Estelle qu'on puisse
expliquer à ceux qui nous regardent des
conseils pour mieux gérer cette rentrée
et se sentir plus zen d'abord notre
humeur elle est liée quand même à des
hormones cérébrales et donc nos hormones
on a un pouvoir dessus c'est les fameux
conseils un peu de grand-mère mais c'est
resynchronisé votre de sommeil vous
recalez pour avoir assez d'ordre de
sommeil vous exposez le plus possible en
septembre à la lumière donc faites des
trajets à pied si possible parce que
tant qu'il y a encore du soleil vous
synthétisez l'hormone du bonheur la
sérotonine et vous régulez l'hormone du
sommeil la mélatonine et puis c'est pas
parce que vous avez pas le temps de
cuisiner que vous devez faire de la
malbouffe il y a des avocats il y a des
noix il y a des choses qui sont bonnes
pour le cerveau
c'est quoi les légumes les fruits les
bons les bons aliments c'est les
aliments qui contiennent des bonnes
graisses
et donc ce sont des antidépresseurs
naturels et puis il y a un secret à la
rentrée c'est de visser dans l'agenda
comme si c'était une contrainte un
engagement vis-à-vis de vous même qui
est de maintenir une activité sportive
parce que c'est vraiment mais ça c'est
vrai plus les gens vont faire du sport
plus on va pouvoir refaire diminuer les
chiffres de consommation des
psychotropes et c'est important parce
que c'est vraiment un antidépresseur
naturel de faire du sport donc pas de
sport j'ai piscine ça veut dire j'ai
piscine et je ne manquerai pour rien au
monde la piscine c'est comme une réunion
de boulot c'est vissé dans l'agenda
j'ai besoin d'une explication j'aime mon
métier de journaliste j'aime mon métier
d'animateur de chroniqueur mais chaque
rentrée je suis stressé comment ça
s'explique c'est hyper paradoxal non
mais non pas du tout d'abord le stress
ne veut pas dire ne veut pas faire
d'abord de la motivation si ça vous
initie et que ça dépasse un certain
seuil c'est mauvais mais le stress c'est
aussi le moment où on réunit notre
énergie et on va à nouveau se concentrer
après une période de vacances ou on
s'est relâché on a relâché le cerveau
etc donc vous vous remontez le taux de
dopamine vous remontez toutes vos
hormones cérébrales et vous vous
préparez en fait pour pour un combat qui
est sain mais c'est pas Olivier l'époque
de la petite enfance où on avait peur
juger ou pas
vous allez tous faire la cour de l'école
je pense que ça va pas ça va t'aider
une consultation immédiate
c'est les heures de sommeil c'est
extrêmement important combien d'heures
de sommeil alors évidemment les gens
face au sommeil combien d'heures de
sommeil en moyenne faut-il avoir pour se
sentir le mieux possible quand même pour
un adulte c'est autour de cette heure
c'est vrai que quand on est quand on est
en dessous de 6 heures de sommeil et
qu'on fait pas de sieste les hormones de
stress augmentent donc l'inflammation du
corps augmente donc l'immunité diminue
et les troubles de l'humeur augmente si
vous pouvez vous obliger de soi par
semaine à vous dire je suis au lit
portable éteint à 22h même si je dors
pas c'est quand même génial parce que
vraiment vous diminuez tous les
marqueurs biologiques de la maladie et
de l'inflammation et vous et vous
améliorez en fait votre résistance au
stress dans la journée donc les galères
du quotidien vous passent complètement
voilà vous les gérez très facilement 22h
au lit sont portables deux fois par
semaine attendez on peut faire plein de
choses intéressantes au lit sans
portable
[Rires]
vous avez dit Marie Estelle le sommeil
c'est aussi extrêmement important
planifier donc pour
la luminosité
de plus en plus vite c'est-à-dire que là
aujourd'hui à 20h enfin maintenant
aujourd'hui vous regardez chez vous 21h
il fait nuit comment comment
rentrer dans ce dans ce tunnel dans les
pays nordiques au début de l'automne les
gens s'exposent à des à des lampes en
fait spéciales diminuent le matin pour
vraiment faire monter les hormones
équilibrer les hormones cérébrales
ça marche pas mal quand vous le faites
tous les matins pendant 2-3 semaines au
début de l'hiver quand même il y a une
diminution du syndrome de dépression
saisonnière après le blues il est allié
que à ça enfin il peut être lié au fait
qu'il y a quelque chose dans votre vie
qui ne vous convient pas et peut-être
que ça va être l'enjeu de cette année de
le modifier un déménagement voilà
changer de travail réorganiser les
choses avec les enfants et puis je pense
qu'il y a un truc très important c'est
de garder des rendez-vous avec chacun de
ces enfants et avec son conjoint sans
les autres c'est à dire le jeudi bah
ouais on a notre partie de tennis on a
notre resto dehors sans les enfants et
ça paraît être de l'organisation mais
une fois que c'est en place ça met un
peu légèreté dans le quotidien en fait
avant d'aller chasser parce que quand on
suit effectivement à la lettre que vous
dites tout est très codifié ça laisse
mais une fois vous lâchez en fait du
coup vous lâchez prise et les choses
roulent toutes seules en fait mais quand
il y a des enfants sincèrement
l'improvisation c'est des galères
surtout quand ils sont petits plus gros
ils sont autonomes ces autres soucis
mais c'est vrai que c'est une
organisation millimétrée voilà il faut
s'organiser pour être moins stressé bah
sincèrement oui ça c'est du vécu avec
avec trois enfants des jumeaux plus je
suis organisé plus je suis cool en fait
on peut aussi bah moi j'ai trois enfants
aussi et on peut aussi déculpabiliser
quand même aussi parce que nous les
femmes on est quand même très sujettes
au cycle hormonal donc il y a des
moments où on a une bonne humeur et puis
d'autres hein un peu les open down ça
c'est normal et donc gérer tout être une
super maman etc c'est un peu ça me fait
penser au bouquin de ma copine la femme
parfaite est une c'est un peu
ça donc déculpabiliser lâcher aussi un
peu lâcher prise aussi quand voilà on
fait pas tout by the book c'est pas
grave voilà c'est sûr que c'est sympa de
la bonne élève et que vous voulez que
tout paniquel vous allez juste rester
vos enfants voilà ça va être
contre-productif il y a quelque chose à
quoi on ne pense pas forcément les
femmes c'est à déléguer aux enfants dès
lors plus jeune âge mais des enfants de
3 ans il y a des choses qui peuvent
faire dans la maison ils sont hyper
contents de le faire en fait la
poussière
l'aspirateurs
des objets pas fragiles pas dangereux
évidemment trois ans vous pouvez
demander bien sûr
psychomotrice et en fait pour eux c'est
extrêmement valorisant de voir qu'ils
ont une responsabilité dans la vie des
grands ils peuvent faire leur lit ils
peuvent ranger leur jouet ils peuvent
trier les feutres qui marchent les
feutres qui marchent pas pour aider le
grand à faire sa trousse en fait il faut
vraiment penser à impliquer tout le
monde tout le monde peut faire quelque
chose il y a pas que vous qui vous êtes
pas Atlas vous portez pas le monde tout
le monde dans la maison peut faire
quelque chose et les enfants sont super
contents de participer s'ils ont pris le
pli tout petit ce sera beaucoup moins
compliqué de leur demander à
l'adolescence alors
vous êtes l'auteur de ce que vous en
avez écrit plein d'autres un mariage
Estelle être parent en temps de crise
oui bah oui effectivement avec le covid
il y avait beaucoup de bouleversements
dans notre dans notre vie la gestion
effectivement des enfants l'éducation
des enfants c'est quand même ce qui a le
plus compliqué au monde est-ce qu'il y a
des conseils peut-être à donner à ceux
qui nous regardent dans le livre en fait
je compile un petit peu tout ce que j'ai
observé pendant trois ans la crise covid
et puis les enfants ont entendu tout le
temps se moquer ce crise sanitaire crise
écologique crise économique la guerre
donc pour eux ils étaient vraiment dans
un climat qui était très anxiogène et
très paralysant parce qu'en fait ils
avaient pas de prise dessus donc j'ai
essayé de faire une rétrospective de ce
qui s'est passé dans notre société
qu'est-ce pourquoi maintenant il y a
tous ces symptômes le harcèlement
scolaire qui augmente etc de quoi est-ce
le symptôme d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé dans notre société
depuis 40 ans et puis de donner des clés
aux parents pour retrouver leur position
d'autorité parentale et donner une
confiance une espérance aux enfants
parce que oui l'État décide de certaines
choses mais au sein de notre foyer nous
sommes les premiers responsables de ce
qu'on transmet à nos petits donc il y a
des témoignages et puis il y a des
chiffres évidemment sur la santé mentale
des jeunes
après le covid dans le cabinet mais dès
le début en fait c'est à dire que le
confinement et c'était en mars 2020
août les adultes ont commencé à
s'effondrer les étudiants ont suivi en
octobre-novembre et voulaient tous
décrocher et en février 2021 on a eu une
vague pédopsychiatrique énorme avec des
tentatives de suicide d'enfants à un âge
où on se suicide pas donc nous on a vu
ça quand on le disait on nous disait on
n'a pas les chiffres parce que les
chiffres ils arrivent toujours plus tard
mais quand les chiffres arrivent c'est
trop tard donc j'ai aussi un rôle à un
moment donné de lanceuse d'alerte mais
aussi un rôle de redonner de l'espoir de
donner des clés de dire voilà journée
oui les troubles alimentaires ont
augmenté oui la consommation de
psychotropes a augmenté de 155% entre
2014 et 2021 chez les jeunes c'est très
préoccupant mais nous on peut faire
quelque chose on est acteur on doit pas
se déprimer parce que sinon bah on a
déjà abandonné nos enfants en fait donc
ce livre est à la fois un constat assez
grave assez lourd une rétrospective
sociologique et historique sur 40 ans et
puis des clés aujourd'hui comment on
peut faire nous dans le monde moderne
qui quand même le monde moderne et ce
qui est un petit peu la famille
disons-le mais donc il y a de l'espoir
quand même mais oui il y a l'espoir on
est là tant qu'on est là tant qu'on est
là tout va bien et en plus il y a des
clés effectivement à découvrir dans ce
livre d'autorité parentale où les
parents ont du mal à imposer leur
autorité aujourd'hui oui je pense que on
a beaucoup de sapé en fait l'idée des
cadres l'idée de l'autorité et donc
l'idée qu'en fait c'est à nous d'être
les premiers exemples et d'être des
modèles inspirants pour nos enfants
c'est très important donc je parle de la
patience je parle du courage je parle de
l'importance du jeu gieu pour que
l'enfant développe son imaginaire dans
un monde où notamment les écrans et puis
une vision très statistique de la vie en
société casse l'imaginaire de l'enfant
comment l'aider à redévelopper cette
ressource intérieure qui va lui
permettre de dépasser les épreuves
toutes les angoisses des crises c'est
aussi dans l'imaginaire qui va trouver
des ressources pour les résoudre quand
il sera adulte aux écrans parce que bien
sûr ça vous écrans mais les écrans
responsables peut-être du mal-être de
ils sont pas responsables c'est à dire
c'est pas les responsables primaires
c'est nous qui avons introduit ces
objets dans la maison mais bien
évidemment qu'ils aggravent tout si vous
dites à l'enfant si tu fais 30 minutes
de télé tu me fais 30 minutes de course
à pied et 30 minutes de lecture déjà
votre enfant ira beaucoup mieux donc
vous serrez la vie ça fond oui vous avez
pas peur
moi j'ai toujours fonctionné comme ça
avec mes enfants c'est l'humour en fait
l'autodérision l'humour voilà enfin ce
que vous appelez d'ailleurs le jeu mais
le jeu verbal aussi et pouvoir se moquer
de soi-même voilà se moquer aussi au
sein de la fratrie rire un peu quoi
enfin pas toujours être le policier là
enfin moi je j'ai pas fait des enfants
pour être L'agent de circulation
essentielles de la politesse alors ça
c'est sûr ça ça dérange pas si tu dis
pas bonjour Si tu dis pas merci tu files
dans ta chambre mais en revanche voilà
on s'en fout pas
un coup de de consoles de jeux et puis
c'est pas grave s'ils sont polis ils
sont bien leur pompe et qui est-ce qui
sont drôles franchement honnêtement moi
je lâchement l'humour c'est un ressort
de l'imaginaire et effectivement c'est
très important parce que vous dites j'en
parle je donne cet exemple dans le livre
en fait on rigole pour mon enfant ne se
de mon fils aîné de ce climat oxygène à
l'école et en fait ça a été vraiment son
outil c'est-à-dire que le fait de tout
tourner en dérision de rigoler de faire
des sketchs a été une ressource une
ressource très très importante bien sûr
que l'humour est la meilleure arme
contre le contre le désespoir dans les
périodes d'anxiogène voilà il faut rire
il faut rire avec avec ce genre n'est-ce
pas
regardez pas possible
non mais c'est très important le rire
c'est un antidépresseur naturel non bah
vous dédramatiser donc vous prenez de la
distance donc les choses ont beaucoup
moins de prix et et bien sûr et du coup
vous trouvez aussi des solutions parce
que quand vous êtes paralysé par
l'angoisse vous trouvez pas de solution
non c'est ça de rire
en fait on se rend compte que c'est pas
grave en fait voilà c'est il y a pire
enfin voilà on passe on peut prendre un
peu de distance pourquoi avec nous ça
n'est-ce pas Maxime de la distance et
puis me prendre peut-être quelques jours
de weekend sympathique
alors que la rentrée vient tout juste de
commencer vous avez le droit bien sûr
évidemment peut-être les week-end aussi
et se mettre des pendant des projets
sympathiques ça aide c'est si le stress
de la rentrée n'est pas correctement
géré et ce qui peut avoir des
répercussions sur la santé mentale
c'est une question
donc a priori ça devrait
rait passer un peu au bout non
on est que Michel tant maximum la route
est longue on va peut-être voir les
conseils que vous donnez marié à celle
du pont merci infiniment d'être venu sur
le plateau de Paf retrouver un rythme ça
bon voilà planifier pour libérer son
esprit prévoir donc anticiper limiter
les imprévus avant toujours des plombées
et faire du sport mais même la marque
c'est génial enfin bon le fait de
marcher moi je moi j'adore ça non mais
ça fait vraiment vraiment